all right I did it you're not gonna
believe it but I did it I found
something good that I can say about
Donald Trump so first let's just recap
the lawfulness he's a horrible egomaniac
I don't really believe he's even really
running for president I've been saying
this probably for six months I think
he's gonna do about three debates the
numbers are gonna keep going up the
media is gonna keep blowing him and then
at some point he's just gonna say all
right I moved the dial enough he's gonna
step aside he's gonna end up being the
attack dog for whoever the nominee is I
think he really likes John Kasich the
Governor of Ohio but we'll see I think
there's a couple other options there but
that's what his plan is and then maybe
he'll try to be secretary of the
Treasury or something like that anyway
Trump is terrible we all know this he's
saying these over-the-top bombastic
things these are not things that a
presidential candidate says these are
not policy things these are just raw red
meat right for just the masses to go
crazy and you know he says these awful
things so one of the things that he said
during the debate that got everyone
crazy
was when megyn kelly called him out on
calling women fat pigs and all those
other things and you know that he said
the Rosie O'Donnell comment of friends
with Rosie Amiens disgusting
that was terrible name dropping anyway
what he doesn't understand is he says
well I'm politically incorrect I think
you guys know if you know me well enough
by now that I am all for political
correctness for being politically
incorrect that is the most important
thing that we need right now in society
but he doesn't erst and there's just a
difference between just being an [ __ ]
and being politically incorrect there
was nothing politically incorrect about
what he said he's just being a dick
point is I think I found something good
about him because during that debate he
actually said something that was fully
true when he said but because he gave
Hillary Clinton money Hillary Clinton
showed up at his daughter's wedding or
what was it a son's wedding whatever it
was and he was the daughters wore his
wedding I don't even remember which
wedding it was said a zillion
like that was the unmasking of
everything he said yeah I as a I'm a
rich guy and what we do as rich people
is we give money to candidates and to me
not only do what we want they show up to
our weddings they'll show up to bar
mitzvahs they don't care don't do
anything and therein lies the great
unmasking that we've needed that
actually was politically incorrect so
really unmask how screwed up the system
is and that you can buy politicians not
just so that they can help you you know
get a land deal or whatever else he's
giving the money for but they're so sold
out and I mean sold out in terms of Sol
D and it's and also sou LED sold out no
soul because they will literally show up
to your wedding if you give them enough
money there are prostitutes and hookers
that's really all they are and he
unmasked that and we need more of that
so for all the reasons that Bernie
Sanders is a hundred percent right on on
money in politics and all that stuff and
we talk about that all the time right
for all of those reasons that Bernie's
right he actually has an ally in Donald
Trump Donald Trump is actually right
about one thing the system screwed up we
gotta fix the system and it all comes
down to money